[Music]
warfare is often like a game of
rock-paper-scissors for every new weapon
developed a counter weapon follows each
player needs to carefully balance and
ensure their opponent do not develop a
power play which has no counter but with
the start of the Cold War and the
invention of the nuclear bomb this
ever-evolving game of
rock-paper-scissors has deteriorated
into a game where each player stock
pause rocks and develops new ways to
hurl them at their opponent technology
has only recently progressed fair enough
to develop a legitimate countermeasure
like the terminal high altitude area
defense system aka Todd but the u.s.
today we're going to investigate how
this technology works and how likely it
is to stop a nuclear threat against the
United States with North Korea's recent
thermal nuclear hydrogen bomb tests and
the continued experimentation of short
and long range missiles the world has
been on edge South Korea has even
deployed both Todd and Patriot systems
despite pushback from China so how do we
stop a hypothetical ICBM incoming from
North Korea countermeasures have been
developed by many of the world's powers
though they are not as sophisticated as
perhaps you would expect and that's for
two reasons one because in 1972 the
United States and Soviet Union signed an
anti-ballistic missile 3d which was
designed to limit the development and
deployment of these defensive
countermeasures and the US only were
through from the treaty to protect the
u.s. from nuclear blackmail from rogue
states like Iran and North Korea and to
because ICBMs are really really hard to
intercept to counter these threats
the US has contracted the top military
engineering groups to develop and
maintain an integrated ballistic missile
defense system or BMDs the system
integrates independent short medium and
long range missile defense systems such
as Patriot Aegis and Todd into one
communication network they are
integrated and supported by a battery of
land and sea-based sensors such as
infrared satellites an x-band Raider
that all have a common communication
line to the command center this allows
new radar systems or mobile Navy vessels
with sensors and interceptors to be
seamlessly incorporated if they are in
the region there are three main phases
of an ICBM the boost phase mid-course
phase and terminal phase each phase have
different challenges in terms of
interception during the boost phase
the US would first detect heat
signatures from a launch with infrared
satellites and communicate this to the
command center
regional Raider would pick up the
missiles and provide accurate tracking
all of this data is processed and a
trajectory probability map is built and
continuously updated throughout the
course of the flight
interception at this point is not likely
as the target is an enemy airspace and
most interceptors are not fast enough to
reach the target before it enters the
mid-course phase in the upper atmosphere
in space with the two or three stage
ICBM the boost phase can last under ten
minutes and propel the vehicle to an
altitude of around 1,200 kilometers
above the surface of the earth or three
times higher than the orbit of the
International Space Station at this
point the projectile can be traveling as
fast as seven kilometers per second or
twenty to twenty-five times the speed of
sound meaning a capable missile can
travel halfway around the planet in
about 45 minutes or less if I just see
based or other ground-based interceptors
are in range short to intermediate range
missiles targeting Japan South Korea or
Guam can be intercepted by the is
kinetic kill vehicle meaning it
physically intercepts the warheads with
a kinetic impact it accomplishes this
with thrusters which allowed to maneuver
in the final phase of engagement this is
not an easy task as the system must
attempt to discriminate threats within
the threat cloud the trek cloud consists
of active warheads decoys and debris in
the case of North Korea it's unlikely
multiple warheads would be used due to
the size and weight constraints but some
primitive decoys are more than likely
the terminal phase is when the warheads
begin to re-enter the atmosphere towards
their targets the terminal high-altitude
area defense or tad is a long-range
missile defense system the targets
missiles at this stage with
installations on the west coast of the
United States Alaska Guam and more
recently South Korea similar to the
Aegis the Tod kill vehicle is a kinetic
kill vehicle with four miniature
boosters to control the projector during
recent tests this platform has been
successful but an engineer's work is
never complete the US was working on a
new interceptor dubbed the MK V or
multiple kill vehicle incorporating a
more advanced version of the Aerojet
surround the central launcher with
multiple killed vehicles that can
independently intercept multiple
warheads it was later replaced by a
similar multi-object kill vehicle as a
tract a collaboration between Raytheon
Boeing and Lockheed Martin no system is
perfect especially ones with such tight
tolerances of success considering the
lack of active threat stress testing
it's likely the BMDs will not have more
than a 50/50 success rate per missile
against a threat like North Korea
multiple interceptors will make an
attempt and it's highly probable the US
will succeed in taking it out if North
Korea decided to attack Seoul it's much
more likely that they would be able to
overwhelm their defenses against the
threats such as Russia things don't look
so good as hundreds of missiles equipped
with ten warheads each independently
tagged at different cities the chance of
a single warhead making a pass is high
Russian technology is simply superior to
North Korea's new hypersonic warheads
are being developed that can change
their direction mid-flight making
predictive tracking almost impossible
even if the ballistic missile defenses
are 100% accurate there are simply more
warheads than interceptors making the
BMD s only a limited capability system
locally North Korea is a limited
capability threat you may have admired
some of the footage I used in this video
like this this this and this they all
came from story blocks calm my channel
literally would not have been possible
without their service when I began this
channel I plan to animate everything but
that is simply way too much work so I
began looking for a stock footage site
that would have suitable footage to use
in places that did not need animation
and that's where story blocks came in
story blocks is the first and only stock
media company offering unlimited free
downloads of member library content for
a modest annual fee of 149 dollars I use
up to 20 or more videos in each episode
that would have cost upwards of $1000
without their service this service is
enabling so many channels like mine to
exist I really can't recommend them
enough and they have stock images and
audio too you can try out their service
for free for seven days by going to
story blocks com4 slash real engineering
as always thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters for
making this channel possible if you'd
like to see more from me the links from
my social media accounts are below on
making efforts to post more educational
content on my Instagram account so check
that out if you're interested